alright sorry for the late start I had a
very very strange tech issue right
before starting where the I have a
wireless mouse that I used to control
stuff and I kind of need it to do
anything on these streams because I'm
very far away from everything and it
just died and yeah I don't know I mean I
had to restart the entire thing but now
we're on and we're here and we have so
much to talk about we're going to be
talking about Michael Cohen's testimony
today explosive testimony testimony that
we knew was going to be smeared and and
attacked as not credible because Michael
Cohen has previously told lies of course
by that standard we could not believe
anything that Donald Trump ever says
again having told somewhere between
eight and twelve thousand lies since
becoming president of the United States
so we will be talking about that also
last night Republican congressman Matt
gates threatened Michael Cohen with we
don't know whether they are real or
made-up claims of mistresses of his and
he is now under investigation by the
Florida State Bar he actually committed
a federal crime by my reading of it so
he should be under investigation by the
Justice Department but at least we have
an investigation from the Florida State
Bar against Matt Gaetz on his because of
his threats to Michael Cohen on the eve
of the testimony I watched most of the
testimony today other than when we were
taping the show itself so any questions
people have about any element of it I am
glad to answer because there was a lot
there and we saw our friend congressman
Rowe Khanna ask questions we saw a
number of Republicans and Democrats ask
questions the entire thing taking 10 or
15 extra minutes to even get started
because of arguments Republicans trying
to use technicalities and and procedural
techniques to prevent the testimony from
even taking place which told us a lot
about their desperation not to have this
timoni take place so we are going to be
getting into all of it welcome if this
is your first david pakman show
livestream on the david pakman show
channel which is rapidly approaching
600,000 subscribers we anticipate we're
gaining about eight to twelve hundred
subscribers a day so we're probably just
a couple of days away from 600,000
subscribers these are really live
meaning you can talk to me you can ask
questions you can send comments the best
way to do it is by using the dollar sign
at the bottom of the chat window that
will pop up I am able to put it up on
screen like so and you will see the
where are they they're there here we go
they're there they're everything going
wrong today every imaginable thing going
wrong there are the Super chats and I
will be getting to them that's the best
way to participate you can also sign up
for memberships at david pakman.com
slash membership if you want me to open
up the phone lines I will do that if we
get 10 new members and as you can see at
the bottom of the screen there there is
a coupon code SAVE 35 which was launched
for my birthday it expires tomorrow
night at midnight the last day of
February it'll give you a $60 membership
for just 25 bucks if 10 people sign up
the phones will be wide open for a while
almost as long as people want because we
usually have dozens of people calling in
and I can't get to everybody unless I
stay here for six hours which I'm not
doing today but I will stay for a while
and I'll open up the phone lines if we
get some new members and feel free to
take advantage of that coupon code
twenty-five bucks for the year instead
of 60 that is a damn good deal don't
troll the live chat please don't troll
the live chat sometimes I have to
actually ban people before the stream
even starts and become a youtube channel
member using the join button if you do
that it will count it towards the ten
new members why not ten new members
patrons or YouTube channel members so
let's let's get into it because there's
so much to discuss let's take a look at
a BBC article
in congressional testimony Michael Cohen
said that Donald Trump directed covert
plans for the Trump Tower Russia
skyscraper even while he denied having
any business in Russia so that may be an
indication that Donald Trump has
committed the crime of lying to
investigators and the reason that that
may be the case we won't know for some
time but you'll remember that Donald
Trump submitted written answers to
Robert Moeller's investigators if in
those written answers Donald Trump told
the lie that he has told many times that
Trump Tower Moscow was nothing that
certainly he wasn't involved he wasn't
being kept up to date Michael Cohen's
testimony under oath today directly
contradicted that saying I was asked
regularly by Donald Trump about the
issue he knew about everything that was
going on he was pushing it forward of
course we know there were plans there
was a builder that had been identified
that is one possible area of criminality
by Trump that was exposed today Cohen
also said Trump knew about a leak of
hack Democratic emails and called him a
racist conman and cheat yeah in fact the
allegation from Cohen is not being fully
represented in that line by the BBC
Cohen claims that Trump knew ahead of
time specifically because Roger stone
told him that he spoke to Julian Assange
and that the dumps of illegal illegally
obtained documents were coming that
directly contradicts multiple statements
from Donald Trump again if he claimed
that under oath in his written answers
to Robert Muller that's another instance
of a crime
lying to federal investigators mr. Trump
hit back he's lying in order to reduce
his prison time there is no indication
that that's true there is no indication
that that's even a mechanism that could
take place Donald Trump of course could
pardon Michael Cohen Michael Cohen said
he doesn't want nor would he accept a
pardon I can't imagine Donald Trump
would offer a pardon but importantly
there is no indication right now that
Michael Cohen stands to benefit in terms
of a shorter sentence as a result of
saying things that Democrats or Trump's
enemies would like I mean he just hasn't
asserted how that would work and there's
no indication that it would Cohen is set
to start a three-year prison term in May
for the campaign finance violation of
paying hush money to one of mr. Trump's
alleged mistresses tax evasion and lying
to Congress
what did Cohen say about the Moscow
project let's see if I can close this
really annoying ad I can in his public
testimony to the House of
Representatives Oversight Committee he
said mr. Trump knew of and directed
plans for a Trump Tower Moscow while
stating publicly that he had no dealings
in Russia at the same time I was
actively negotiating in Russia for him
Cohen testified he would look at me in
the eye and tell me there's no business
in Russia and then go out and lie to the
American people by saying the same thing
in his way he was telling me to lie this
is how mob guys tell you to lie okay
they don't say I need you to go and tell
lies to a house panel or a Senate panel
or federal investigators they look at
you and they say there's no business in
Russia
you understand me Michael there's no
business in Russia
yes mr. Trump I understand no business
in Russia and then Michael Cohen goes
out and says it and at no point does
Donald Trump actually say you're going
to need to commit the crime of lying to
investigators by saying the following he
just makes clear the story is there's no
business in Russia that is a very
interesting sort of peek behind the
curtain about how this stuff works and
you know that as always in the same way
that it's not super reasonable to expect
that there are going to be videos of
Trump and Putin arranging to collude on
the election it's not a reasonable
expectation to have that be your
standard and in that same way just
because there's not a recorded
conversation where Trump says Michael
let's get our lies straight so we can
tell them to investigators this is how
Trump tells someone to lie without
saying I need you to lie very very
interesting to see exactly how it is
that that works Cohen has been convicted
of lying to Congress when he testified
in 2017 that attempts to build a Trump
skyscraper in Moscow had stopped by
January 2016 right we know that there
lies because Cohen's been convicted of
them right that that's the incredible
thing about all of us
he has since acknowledged negotiations
continued until June 2016 in the midst
of the campaign the real estate project
didn't ultimately go ahead as we knew
Cohen apologized for his earlier false
statements to Congress which were
reviewed and edited by mr. Trump's
lawyers that's another way to get people
to lie which is Trump never says
anything
Cohen prepares what he plans to say and
then Trump's lawyers edit it and those
edits don't actually correspond with the
real world or what any normal person
would call the truth
Cohen suggested federal prosecutors in
New York are investigating some
unspecified crime involving Trump that
was interesting what did Cohen say about
the email leaks this was a big deal
Cohen said he was in Donald Trump's
office in July 2016 when Rogers stone
called the then Republican presidential
candidate the witness said mr. stone
rang mr. Trump to let him know he had
been speaking to WikiLeaks founder
Julian Assange who told them there would
be a massive dump of emails within a
couple of days
that would put politically embarrass
Hillary Clinton's White House campaign
Cohen said mr. Trump responded along the
lines of wouldn't that be great
Trump has denied having prior knowledge
about WikiLeaks his disclosure of DNC
emails during the election obviously
that was not true and for me the the
Cohen testimony today is not mind
blowing in the sense that anything here
is surprising right or or unexpected
this is exactly how we believe Donald
Trump operates what's interesting is the
specificity with which Michael Cohen was
able to lay out how it works let me give
you an example anyone who knows anything
about how Trump runs his businesses
knows that he's involved in everything
down to the finest detail right nothing
is taking place without Trump's
involvement Trump is known for getting
involved on the phone with whoever is
selling the
windows to the development company for a
building that Donald Trump is building
and he will get involved at that micro
level the idea that Roger stone who by
the way denied having done the stuff but
but now we we know that he did the idea
that Roger stone and Don Jr who Trump
notoriously thinks is a horrible
horrible but that who makes horrible
judgments we've heard that before from
Trump there is no way that Trump would
allow Roger stone to be working with
Julian Assange and WikiLeaks and have no
knowledge of it there is no way that Don
Jr would be arranging meetings with
Russian lawyers to get dirt on Hillary
without Donald Trump knowing about it
every single solitary step of the way
that was never believable and thanks to
Michael Cohen we now know some of the
specific dynamics of how the entire
thing went down and that is
extraordinarily illuminating let's see
what else we have here the messages
which US authorities say were hacked by
Russian intelligence caused the damaging
rift among Democrats by exposing how
party officials preferred mrs. Clinton
over her challenger for the presidential
nomination Bernie Sanders it's good that
we learned that I mean aside from all
the criminality obviously that's a good
thing that that we learned and now we
are more prepared to deal with that in
the 2020 election Roger stone a
self-proclaimed political dirty
trickster is currently facing charges of
lying to Congress about his
communications with WikiLeaks
and witness tampering so it's all coming
together there is there is a very
consistent picture here and then now we
have some sort of op-ed which maybe
maybe we will get to or maybe we won't
so that's the set up of what happened
today do I believe Michael Cohen for the
most part he is not saying the types of
things that are open to distortion
unless you just don't literally don't
believe a word he's saying if you think
he's making everything up he's are going
to be in big trouble because after
everything that's happened the House
Oversight Committee is not going to
tolerate someone coming in and whole
cloth concocting all of this sort of
if you grant that that's unlikely as any
reasonable person should at this point
then the question is can we corroborate
the things that Michael Cohen said here
and the answer is we will see we will
see Michael Cohen multiple times today
saying that a lot of this stuff
there is evidence for it in the hands of
investigators at SD NY or with Robert
Moeller's team and we may we may
ultimately see that but the reality is
that if only five to ten percent like if
Cohen worst-case-scenario Cohen lied
about 90 percent of the stuff it's still
insane it's still rising to the level of
criminality by not only the President of
the United States but by others
associated with the campaign from family
this Allan white weiselberger guy who
runs I don't remember if it was Trump
the Trump Organization or is the lawyer
for the Trump Organization even if 90%
of what Cohen said the worst 90% can be
written off as lives which I don't
believe that it can you've still got
explosive mind-blowing testimony here
okay I see a lot of people who want to
check in via super chat so let's get to
that I'll scroll back up and before we
do that we are by the way we are looking
for 10 new members and I'll open up the
phone lines and there are a thousand
people watching many of whom want to
call in I'm glad to open up the phone
lines but that costs money and we want
to make that up by bringing in some new
members there's a coupon code you can
use on the $60 per year membership
because of my birthday earlier this
month the coupon code save 35 will drop
a $60 membership down to only 25 bucks
ok you can sign up for that at david
pakman.com slash membership people who
have done that include John Gwynn
neuquén yeah I think that's how it's
pronounced I never know that that's
silent and at the beginning John Gwynn
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership
Darrius give us or jiva's has signed up
a david pakman.com slash membership and
Joe Rosser has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership so that's
three
out of 10 and I will open up the phone
lines when we get to 10 new 10 new
members YouTube subscribers channel
subscribers channel members or patrons
so let's now get to the Super chats ok
who is first here and rule in court sent
a $2.00 super chat with no question or
comment thank you very much I appreciate
that
Matthew long with a 499 super chat hey
David I've heard people on the left say
Berlin Bernie is in fact a socialist my
understanding was he's a social democrat
at best what do you think Bernie's
policies are that those of a social
democrat right now he says he came from
the school of thought of democratic
socialism in the 70s and that may well
be the case but the policies he's
advocating for right now as a member of
the Senate and a presidential candidate
are social democracy policies not
socialist policies Jackson with a $5
super Chad besting Matthew by a penny
for the top super chat of the night as
much as I want to do you think this as
much as I want it to do you think this
hearing will actually matter skeptical
Trump faces consequences while he's
president sad I don't disagree with you
Jackson I mean the the hearing today
with Michael Cohen exposed rampant I
mean just absolutely rampant criminality
and as I mentioned if 10% of it is
accurate Trump's implicated but it's
going to come down to public opinion
influencing Republicans as to whether
they want to just play the partisan
games and continue to defend Donald
Trump like such as people like Matthew
Gates have been doing or if they're
going to say this is too much
right for the good of the country we
have to act here and for our own
conscience we have to act if they have
one I don't know that they do Athea
phobe sends a $2 super chat saying you
Plus Kyle kolinsky I presume equal best
progressives run for office someday all
right Thank You Thea phob appreciate
that the progressive voice
a dollar ninety nine super chat he says
thoughts on the trend of cuckoldry
amongst anarchists know that so
yesterday the progressive voice was
streaming I think it was and I it was a
stream about me the progressive voice
known in some circles as progressive TMZ
who does meta he goes meta on
progressive media he was doing a stream
somehow related to me and I popped in
for five seconds and merely asked can
you comment on the trend of cuckoldry
among and caps I think I said
anarcho-capitalists and he is now
trolling me the difference is he paid to
troll me and I appreciate that very very
good to hear from you
Doug Condor sends a five dollar super
chat hey mister P please agree that I
assume even Michael Cohen will lead to
Trump errs leaving soon I gotta be
encouraged know unfortunately the Trump
astounding Donald Trump okay partially
because of what moral psychology teaches
us about group ashiness Google that
Jonathan Hite has a lot of good writing
about it um partially because of a
mechanism called cognitive dissonance
and partially because they just don't
actually care right they just don't want
Democrats to win they don't want the
left to win they aren't going to abandon
Trump so forget about it we've got to
win without them
Jamal Swift with a five-dollar super
Chad did any member of the committee
strike you is not using their time
effectively yes and I don't remember
well listen everybody all of the
Republicans who used their time to read
mean tweets into the record to the
extent that they weren't enquiries and
were using their time total and complete
waste of time but I did see there was a
towards the beginning there was a female
congresswoman sitting in the back near
the Chairman Elijah Cummings who I
thought didn't use her time particularly
well yeah there were others although I'm
struggling to remember exactly who Hasan
jf would you debate Kyle I presume they
mean kolinsky on Bernie's venez way
tweets I don't know what the debate
would be because I have no idea what
Kyle's view is but maybe I don't know
Jackson sends a five-dollar super chat
TMZ voice back at it with the stupid
questions in chat and super Chad may
have to rename him to the Daily Mail of
progressive politics very sad it would
be a dark day in a progressive
independent media if the progressive
voice lost the title of progressive TMZ
and was instead renamed the Daily Mail
of progressive politics I don't want to
see that so let's let's hope it doesn't
happen Terry James by the way if you're
wondering how to get in and get your
message on screen these are super chats
using the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window Terry James says how do
you respond to people who say that
universal health care welfare etc are
forcing people to be compassionate
rather than true compassion it's not
forcing people to do anything if you're
a doctor you treat people when they come
in and need to avail themselves of your
services if you're a nurse the same
thing applies it's not forcing people to
do anything it's creating a system that
is better for all is better economically
is better socio-culturally and is not
even what's unique is that we don't have
health care for everybody we're the
outlier not everybody else don't allow
the the position that is actually the
most common one among OECD countries to
become the extremist position that's
that's how they win okay I've got a few
new members to thank as I've mentioned
I'm looking forward to opening up the
phone lines this evening but I will do
it if and when we get 10 new supporters
via our website or via YouTube channel
memberships or patreon we have a coupon
code listen here's the bottom line with
this membership stuff I think
memberships at six dollars a month for
everything we do plus the extra content
you get extra content as a member I
think it's more than worth it I think 60
dollars a year is more than worth it
but if you don't think it's worth it or
you can't afford six
bucks a month or 60 for the year we have
a coupon code that expires tomorrow
night at midnight when February ends
that coupon code is save 35 and it'll
drop a $60 membership to just 25 dollars
okay read about it right at the bottom
$60 membership for 25 bucks
with the coupon code save 35 at join
pakman.com that's like two dollars and
eight cents a month okay if you can't
afford two dollars in eight cents a
month and you like what we do but you're
opting not to support the show that's
really sad I'm not gonna insult you but
it just makes me sad but fortunately
we're already at three new members and
there's a few more I want to thank I
thank Darius already did I thank Joe
Rosser I did write Darius and Joe uh I
didn't or I did Joe Rosser while I'm
thanking you again
Jason Hockley is new member number four
and Nathaniel Taylor is new member
number five ten is the target and when
we get there I will be opening up the
phone lines and I am very very excited
to hear from you today okay Zenda crust
has sent a five dollar super chapped
sender chris says how can the Israeli
left and parties like merits steer
Israel in the right direction
since Netanyahu is getting so extreme
also do you like David Dole I've only
seen a couple clips by David Dole and
the two clips I saw I agreed with him I
don't know a bigger picture what is what
his views are but seems like a perfectly
nice guy and the two clips I saw we're
good how can the Israeli left and merits
tear Israel in the right direction okay
here who am I to say what Israeli
politicians should do but if I were on
the Israeli left I would do two things I
would number one harp on the fact that
there is literally no chance for
productive peace talks if Benjamin
Netanyahu is the Prime Minister just
period okay yes there's also no chance
if Hamas is controlling Gaza there's no
question about that but on the Israeli
side if Benjamin Netanyahu
as Prime Minister there will not be
productive peace talks because it's not
in his interest point out as I may do on
the program tomorrow if I have time that
not only is Netanyahu aligned with the
most extremist religious elements of the
Israeli right
he's also increasingly aligned with
racist elements of the Israeli right and
do not allow Netanyahu to control the
discourse around Israeli security
because that's how he always ends up
winning by scaring people that he's the
only one who will keep you safe it's a
very neocon thing to do that we've seen
here in the US the Israeli left has to
paint a really clear picture of how a
lot of the things in Etten yahoo has
done are not actually crucial to
Israel's security and that there are
much better ways of maintaining Israeli
security while moving forward in terms
of the israeli-palestinian conflict and
you know but what do I know I just some
dude in the United States
Zenda crust says would you debate
Michael Brooks on far versus center left
I don't even know what that means far
versus center like what would the debate
just about who is cooler or I mean I
think debates usually have to be about
something specific Johnny knew win or
win sends a $6 super chap the high super
chat of the evening Johnny and win it's
just so hard for me to imagine that
that's actually how it's pronounced
but listen Who am I to tell you how do
you pronounce your last name Johnny
Nguyen neuen win win but please say
omelette omelette omelette yeah that
just does not sound right to me and by
the way let me see if I can pull this up
there was a controversy I just want to
make sure I can do this see if I can
find it there was a controversy because
I went when Donald Trump was at the
omelet station I pronounced it omelet
and people were furious and they said no
David it's omelet it's two syllables
what I want to point out to you is that
oh this might be the wrong dictionary
this dictionary doesn't have it Wow
most dictionaries list
both pronunciations this one does not
this is embarrassing
oh here it is both pronunciations
omelette and omelettes are appropriate
and I learned English as a Second
Language and the way I pronounce it is
omelette and Marian Webster says that it
is absolutely an appropriate
pronunciation okay let's get back to the
super chats thore 18b e/m is a new
youtube channel member that makes six
for the evening
zài Vox is a new member that makes seven
and Ben Fournier is a new member that
makes eight we are 80 percent of the way
to me opening up the phone lines sign up
on our website we have a coupon code
right down there save 35 get a year
membership for 25 bucks I would make a
strong case that the show is worth two
dollars a month and I hope you'll agree
and sign up because I would love I would
absolutely love to open the phone lines
to you momentarily
Elias sriracha's says you could have a
bigger base if you did a Spanish show I
don't know that that's the case because
if most of the audience on this channel
doesn't speak Spanish
so if I start putting Spanish content on
this channel I think a lot of people
wouldn't like it and they might
unsubscribe and if I start a new channel
that's a Spanish language channel I'm
starting from scratch so I don't know
I'm unsure about the opportunity there
Patrick
Ericson sends a two hundred and nine
Swedish kronor super chat I don't know
how much that is but it sounds like a
lot might be ten bucks and no question
or comment but I appreciate that
Jordan Berlin says love your work pack
daddy I'm from Australia so don't follow
us politics too much but your commentary
is very professional and informative
thanks thank you I appreciate it
Orphic with a $50 super chat by and
large the biggest super chat of the
evening says hey David I apologize for
this blame it on our capitalist society
I want to give a shout out to Kim
Iverson on
YouTube she provides unique commentary
and is very articulate I suggest for you
and your audience to check her out you
are my favorite still okay good
I like a good thing I'm still your
favorite and I don't know who Kim
Iverson is but if it was worth $50 to
let me know that it is worthy of me
exploring and seeing what she is all
about and then Norfolk follows up with a
second super chat omelette du fromage
very very nice very nice Alex photo man
says another Aussie fan here of David's
progressive political commentary very
good John Harris no any books on the
psychology of politicians I don't know
about the psychology of politicians but
the psychology of politics I'm actually
reading Jonathan heights the it's not
the rational the rational mind the
rational brain the what's it called the
not rational the righteous the righteous
mind or the righteous brain and it
explains a lot about how politics works
at a psychological level Joe Rader says
everybody should tune in to SpaceX's
stream on Saturday at 1:48 a.m. Central
Time I guess for the DM one mission to
the International Space Station it will
be the test of a commercial launch
vehicle for astronauts sounds
fascinating
I'll probably be sleeping Sabrina Zafar
says hey David do you feel the
mainstream media is beginning to
unjustly attack Bernie similarly to how
the right wing attacked Hillary in 2016
I am seeing some smearing of Bernie
Sanders but I don't think there's right
now a concerted effort to smear Bernie
although I'm open to having my mind
changed for sure okay we have an insane
number of new members that I need to
thank and we're gonna open the phones
Laura chambers Thank You Jacob lame
burrs or Lambert it would be cool if it
rhymes with chambers but I don't think
it does Jacob Lambert has signed up Kyra
dinza is a new member sebastian brown
Jennifer hunter someone canceled their
membership which is depressing but
that's okay we won't count
bet against anybody Beth Lowry or lower
E has signed up tom Flanders is a new
member and I think I already thanked
Nathaniel Taylor so that does it that
that means we are going to open the
phone lines let me get set up for that I
want to make sure I don't inadvertently
flash anybody's phone numbers on the
screen people were getting trolled
recently if you want to start calling in
at six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty you can do that I will look
at there was another super chat here
Terry James says if black Americans want
reparations should they focus more on
getting support from the public so
politicians won't think it will cost
them votes among blue-collar whites yes
I mean if that is going to be made a
priority then I believe that they should
although I questioned whether that
should really be a legislative priority
and we could we could debate that
ondrea's peterson says Packman all by
you in the crew a round of beer in
Sweden so we can discuss politics you
make America great in my eyes that would
be great I'm looking to get to Sweden
soon I was a few months ago I was in
Helsinki Finland I was in Holland
Estonia I was in Copenhagen Denmark
loved all of them pros and cons to all
different things I liked about each but
I would love to get to Sweden soon I
almost went I almost set up a plan to go
in April but then I looked at the
weather and decided it's just not really
the best time to go to Sweden so I hope
to get to Sweden soon I don't know
exactly when it will be but there will
be an announcement that's for sure okay
let me see if I can get set up for live
calls here always want to make notes
about who's calling it's sort of like a
report card and then if someone makes a
terrible terrible faux pas is just
boring I make a note for our system and
that might make it so in the future I
don't pick up that's just a warning to
everybody okay six one seven eight three
zero forty seven fifty let's open the
phone lines first to our caller from the
six four seven
area code caller from six four seven who
is this where are you calling from
hey David this is Sebastian calling from
Canada
hey how's it going Sebastian I wanted to
just touch on something you mentioned
during the last livestream which is uh
whether or not Canadians can donate I
don't think we can but you can volunteer
for a Bernie campaign if you want I know
a couple people who did it last time
yep you can make calls but anyway I want
to ask is Pat with you doing a live
stream no he's not no no Pat Pat is not
he who knows what Pat is doing now but
he's certainly not with me okay well
that's good because I wanted to ask you
some questions about Pat those questions
would be more you know I as Pat's
employer I am bound by a number of
different agreements where it could be
against Massachusetts labor law for me
to say things about Pat that he's not
saying for himself okay well I mean I
was just afraid that if he was in the
room you might be a little more hesitant
but I'll go ahead and you go and tell me
what you feel comfortable things okay
under the law sure um so Pat has no idea
who Lewis is we have actually set up
Pat's YouTube account where any david
pakman show video in which Louis appears
it's like it doesn't exist it's like a
black mirror episode where there's like
a blocker that someone puts on so pat
pat has it has no clue and in fact we'll
have to bleep this section Pat has no
idea anything about Louis now what do
you think would happen if they met I
think it would be a real problem I think
it would be I think it would be really
tragic actually I don't know that and
neither of them could handle it and I
have to ask you like so if Lewis tried
to come back would you be forced to pick
one of the other or do you think they
could work together or like how do you
think that all would work out if Lewis
tried to come back I think he would have
to work his way back up and he would
have to start again as an unpaid intern
and
you know it's a meritocracy here and
then see if he could display spat oh
that's really terrible well you know I'm
also just kind of concerned that Pat
might be making some moves to take over
the show like does he run the YouTube
channel for example what do you mean by
run like does he have access to the
login credentials or do you do it or do
you both do it well YouTube now you
don't have to have the login credentials
YouTube now has has roles so you can
assign people the ability to post
comments as the channel or to upload
videos or like the master password so
there's different roles it's not a
question of does he have the credentials
I mean my concern is that so the the URL
that you have on YouTube is still just
mid-week politics from the old name of
the show and i'm concerned that that
leaves the door open to Pat potentially
trying to stage a coup and so I think if
you want to assert your control of the
show you really need to change it to say
the David Pakman show we do so go to
youtube if you go to youtube.com slash
the david pakman show it just redirects
our channel is old enough that you can't
it's hard to explain but we've got the
david pakman show as well and it all
goes to the same channel very good
questions all right I don't let you go
because there's a lot of people holding
we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
our next caller is from the 9 1 0 area
code caller from 9 1 0
introduce yourself what's on your mind
today hey David this is Daniel and
coughing let's speak with you what's
going on um I wanted to talk really
quick about Bernie versus Trump so I
noticed in his campaign video rollout
and you know since he's been making
speeches and sort of like getting
started on the trail that he is blowing
sort of for the ad hominem at Trump
which is something that I was worried
that he wouldn't do but I'm glad that he
is I see that he's calling him a racist
and going with pathological liar and a
fraud which I thought is good I was
worried that he would focus too much on
just straight policy which i think is
also important that he needs to do but I
kind of wanted to see him take it like a
step further and I was wondering how he
thought this would play out if he like
really pushes the ad hominem against
Trump and like calls him basically like
a [ __ ] like a business failure and
basically calls him stupid I mean cuz he
really is just I don't know that it
works well I don't know that it works
well because Trump has this ability to
insult other people and remember there's
also a difference between ad hominem and
just an insult and ad hominem would be a
personal attack meant to refute a
particular argument which we would
consider invalid then there can also
just be insults like if I just go up to
someone on the street and say you're
stupid it's not an ad hominem in the
sense of the way that it responds to an
argument it's just an insult actually
stupid is sort of an assessment of
intelligence so maybe that's not even
the right example but in any case I
don't think it would work well for
Bernie I think that Trump has the
particular combination of personality
and sycophantic followers where Trump
doing it works one way and others trying
to do it which of Trump works a
different way yeah my thing is Ben I
just
III I just really was hoping and your
burning for my favorite candidate
definitely on policies and everything
but regardless whoever the nominee was I
was just always hoping that they'd
wouldn't be afraid to get in the mud
with chrome because that's what I hated
us they're gonna have to get in the mud
but I think there's ways to get in the
mud without just flinging insults at
Trump right so that's the that's the key
you need to know how to respond part of
it is not letting Trump get under your
skin that's a big part of it and then
you need a strategy that will be equally
interesting to debate viewers for
example that's not just you responding
with insults because I think that that
would not work super well okay okay I
appreciate it
okay yep thanks for the call great to
hear from you let's go next to our
caller from the 484 area code caller
from 484 what's going on hi this is
Brendan from Pennsylvania I love this
hey bro first I wanted to ask if hi I
wanted to ask if you think that
including trade school in the umbrella
free public college would be a useful
idea and in terms of the difference
between you and Kyle kolinsky yesterday
he posted a video about the tweets been
venezuela tweets talking about how he
viewed those tweets as like the
humanitarian aid portion as like bernie
trying to say he wanted to send in
weapons so i think that was like the
clarification for like why there would
need to be a debate there i I have a
hard time believing that I mean I guess
I should see what Kyle is up to but it's
hard for me to imagine knowing Kyle that
he would argue that Bernie Sanders
tweets could be constituted as Bernie
advocating for sending weapons to
Venezuela it's very hard for me to
imagine that but I'll check it out it
was it was yeah it was funny because in
my youtube feed it was your video and it
said like Bernie has obviously correct
tweets and then under it was this video
that said Bernie swings and misses on
now yeah okay so let me get back the
bromine so can you restate the first
part of your question yeah so I just was
curious as i'ma current college student
and you know I've had both sorry yeah
yeah okay trade schools so vocational
high schools are usually public so
there's no issue there trade schools
that one would go to after high school
there's a couple problems with making
them free one is that very often you're
not getting a degree okay so the idea
that we're this is going to be an
association for high school or for
colleges and universities a lot of those
trade schools you don't get an academic
degree so that makes it very dubious
because it's much harder to draw the
line also a lot of those are for profits
and you know the government is not going
to be funding tuition for for-profit
schools the whole idea here is that at
the first eight state schools so I see
it as complex okay and you said it's the
distinction is between treaties and oh
so what I said was vocational high
schools okay
you learn a trade in many cases but it's
high school and it's already public so
the question doesn't really apply to
that and then the rest of my answer was
about if you're talking about things
that come after high school gotcha
if I could ask one more thing it's about
the Trump being kind of awfully weirdly
nice about Bernice and like that not
nice but you know like being kind of
calm about you know his response to
Bernie Sanders entering the race I'm
curious if you think that has anything
to because when I think of Donald Trump
I think he really only cares about his
immediate family and his ego so part of
and I apply that to everything that he
does when I look at his action so when I
looked at you know his response to
Bernie entering the race I think I see
that as is it is it Trump kind of
feeling sheeted that he ran against the
not most popular Democratic candidate so
he kind of self he kind of wishes that
he did because he wants to have be in
the most popular candidate maybe there's
I've taken a couple questions now about
why is Trump not going after Bernie that
much but he said crazy bernie is now in
the race so I mean he's he's he's doing
it I don't see that he's maybe he's just
busy with other stuff but he certainly
hasn't shied away from from doing the
crazy Bernie thing okay well okay thank
you for calling before we get to the
next caller let me mention one super
chat here Beth says hi I got the $25
membership because they got my tax
refund today and have 15 bucks till
payday
it's pronounced Lau re like loud run for
office you have my vote are well you
might not live where I would be running
Beth so that that could be a problem
Spencer Riggi is a new member thanks
Spencer Adam Ramadan has signed up on
our website and Sophia gland Orff has
signed up I mentioned Laura chambers
already okay let's go to our next caller
our next caller is hmm let's go to the
eight one five area code caller from
eight one five where are you calling
from Willard name hey what's going on
David this is Mike in Chicago hey Mike
hey I got a question so I see on Twitter
are you familiar with the
less movement the African descendant of
slaves their main goal is to get
reparations okay and a lot of the tweets
that I'm seeing they're saying no votes
for Democratic Party unless they bring
something tangible for African Americans
so what are your views of reparations
and do you think it's an issue they
should keep pushing for wait so you're
sort of saying don't vote for any
Democrat who's not for reparations for
black people yeah yeah because they're
basically saying that there's some
people on Twitter that say Democrats
always have to come here to votes but
they don't burn anything tangible to the
table perhaps can American voters and a
lot of them are pushing for reparations
I gotcha but so my question is if
they're saying don't vote for Democrats
are they going to vote for Republicans
no they're just saying no vote at all
they're saying they're willing to deal
with Trump and that their vote has to be
earned so my question is do you think
that that's a tactic to get people to
not vote and are you for reparations do
you think that's something that's
possible
what are your thoughts on that I think
that it is extraordinarily unlikely that
reparations are going to be a successful
part of a candidacy if that is made the
number one focus so I think as a
strategy it's not good it's not a good
idea I think anyone who is advocating
for non voting is making a mistake it's
just it we've we've seen the theory and
we've seen the practicality of it and
anybody who is saying if you don't get X
simply don't vote that's how people who
are even worse end up getting into power
and making circumstances even worse for
us so I just completely reject any
movement that's advocating not voting
under any circumstances full-stop I
agree with that and one of the points
they made too is that Native Americans
were given land
casinos in that and you know black
Americans kind of got the short end of
the stick so you don't think
maybe not reparations in general we're
just money is given but maybe tax breaks
for that demographic I mean do you think
that there's anything for the people who
are the descendants of slaves
oh yeah well yeah oh okay
listen I'm open to seeing a proposal I I
would be glad to review a proposal and
if someone says well if we're gonna do
that we also really should be looking at
any descendants of people who were in
japanese-american internment camps then
you know make a proposal and let's look
at it and and see where we get but I
would be shocked if it was a winning
political strategy for anybody thanks
for the call appreciate hearing from you
let's go next to our caller from the 6-3
one area code caller from 6:31 who's
this where are you calling from
hello um hello this is Patrick I'm a New
Yorker but I moved to Montana where you
go oh it's very white cool it's very
nice very beautiful hope you like I
personally I love the diversity of New
York it would be tough for me to move to
such a white place oh I I love the
mountains and I'm a very outdoorsy guy
so it's just it's heaven for me all
right but my question really lies with
Jim Johnson and his statement during the
the Cohen hearing today about how he
said that all of this was orchestrated
by Lanny Davis and I wanted to know what
your take on that was well what do you
mean by orchestrated I mean Lanny
Davis's work for Michael Cohen right and
and so the I mean yes I saw that and the
framing was this isn't someone who
should even be testifying this is
someone who is going to jail partially
for lying he's about to go to jail
prison and it would be unheard of to
have this person testifying were it not
for the political influence of Lanny
Davis a friend of the Clintons this is
all being done to smear Trump blah blah
blah blah blah but listen what what
Cohen presented today is
extraordinarily valuable he implicated
the President of the United States and
multiple crimes the idea that this is
not relevant and valuable testimony is
an absolute and total joke so you know I
guess depends on what you mean by
orchestrated he represented my villain
and coordinated the event yeah do you
think that the that the Republicans are
kind of grasping at straws with using
Lanny Davis as their crutch to support
their argument that this whatever Cohen
says it incredible of course they have
been reeking of desperation this entire
time it started with spending ten
minutes trying to use a procedural
motion to prevent the testimony from
even happening on the basis of when
Cohen's written statement was delivered
to them then they regularly asked for
mean tweets to be entered you know
negative statements on Twitter about
Cohen to be entered into the record they
everything they did wreaked of
desperation and you know in the end it
may not even matter I don't know that
anybody's going to face consequences as
a result of Cohen's testimony I hope I'm
wrong but in the end you know how these
things have been going yeah for me okay
thanks for the call appreciate it
let's see let's go to our next caller
from the 607 area code who's calling
from 607 today 607 I hear you breathing
yeah hello hey who's this yes this is
Gayle I'm calling from Pennsylvania
what's going on Gabe I listen much I've
been talking to my friend about this and
I was wondering what your position on
women and combat roles in the military
was Oh who's your friend his name is
Jordan mm-hmm Jordan Peterson yeah
actually you were talking to Jordan
Peterson about women in combat role yeah
totally where where was that now just
going oh you were kidding okay sorry I
am fine with women in combat roles as
long as they can
meet whatever the physical requirements
are for completing the necessary tasks
sort of like with you know being a
firefighter if the job requires being
able to drag a hundred and fifty pound
person on average 50 feet in under 15
seconds and a woman can do it then you
could do the job fair enough
my friend is basically saying that women
are more predisposed feeling more
empathetic and they most likely wouldn't
be willing to like be able to like shoot
somebody or whatever mmm okay how did
they come up with that idea is this just
their feeling um I haven't pressed on
too much about it but I said but I think
that's mostly what he's feeling about it
and do you think that that's a good
reason to keep women out of combat roles
if they're physically able to do the
jobs no I don't believe so but I'm I'm
not come on uh I don't really know much
about like I don't really know much
about like women being predisposed to
that to like more feeling more
empathetic or whatever so I'm not
completely married to that argument I
don't think there's much research down
there anything yeah and so if I
understand the art the argument is women
shouldn't be in combat roles in the
military because of their feelings right
that's is that the idea I suppose yeah
doesn't sound like a very good argument
to me no yeah I would tell Jordan to
maybe come up with a better reason that
that would be my advice to you thanks
for the call okay
appreciate it let's go next to our
caller from the nine five one area code
who's calling from 951 today
yeah I did it my name is Alexis I'm from
Riverside California I've been listening
for a long time I'm a huge fan
hey Alexis what's going on okay so my
question was I think it was last week
you were talking about Andrew Yang's
Universal income the idea and but when
you were referencing it you were talking
about how it was $1,000 a month but then
when you would represent a 10,000 yes as
I as I've been admonished for now many
many times I miss $12,000 a thousand a
month is twelve thousand and ten
thousand a month ten thousand a year
would be 833 a month so the numbers were
not quite adding up okay so I thought I
thought maybe you knew something I
didn't know twelve times a thousand is
definitely twelve thousand awesome thank
you I do have a follow-up question
though okay um just personally if you
were to pick the next Democratic
candidate where are you more Bernie or
you more Andrew Young uh I don't know
that I'm ready to say right now I mean
my top three candidates are yang Bernie
and Warren Warren interviews terribly I
mean when she's interviewed she comes
off as like the least personable I mean
it's just her interviews are a disaster
but most of her policies I agree with
and I think her ability to get things
done is a positive trait Bernie I was my
candidate in 2016 and I continue to
agree with most of his ideas I would
have the only concern being are is the
fact that he failed to achieve the
nomination in 2016 even with Democratic
meddling going to in some way come back
to hurt him and then with Andrew yang
again I think he is extraordinarily
bright great ideas my concern there is
is he going to be able to get traction
and I hope that he does right the dream
would be Bernie and yang you know
together really as you're buying ticket
yeah you know yeah is BP I think that
would be fantastic yeah
Andrew Yang's an interesting guy and
he's been getting more media attention
lately he was on Joe Rogan he was on fox
business and a bunch of places we're
gonna try to get him back on in the next
couple of weeks
Oh that'd be great yeah the dough broken
oh that was a really good move for him
yeah he's got a lot of a wide fan base
and and it seems like he's gonna be any
Bates which is the most important next
step get into those debates absolutely
absolutely
all right well thank you thank you so
much David okay Alexis thanks for
calling hope to hear from you again
let's take a couple more calls maybe the
let's go to the 435 area code I don't
recognize 435 sometimes when I don't
recognize an area code it's Canada
well where is 435 from is with me yeah
that's you it's in the snowy mountains
of Utah Oh Utah okay well low population
state may be another reason I don't
recognize this is the area code yeah
I've been listening to show for a while
I I know that your stance is that you
definitely don't think that impeachment
is the way to get Trump out of the
office it's all about get out to vote
which I agree with it would be clear
it's not that I'm against impeachment or
that I don't think Trump has done
impeachment worthy things it's that at
this point we are 20 months out from the
election and my instinct is that it's
going to take that long to remove him by
impeachment anyway if that were to take
place so like let's just vote him out in
2020 right okay so that basically
answers my question I was mostly
wondering if you still see it as a
worthwhile thing because from my
standpoint the the debauchery that's
gone on during this presidency yeah I
think out of a matter of principle we
should be pushing for impeachment if
possible yeah it's really not like I
remember wasn't it once we have valid
articles of impeachment for impeachable
offenses file impeachment proceedings
and put it over to the side
you know the the reality is that it
doesn't seem that Republicans in the
Senate would actually vote to remove the
house would start articles of
impeachment then the Senate would would
have to decide on it so I'm not saying
don't do it I'm just saying let's not
rest on that as the way to remove Trump
because it's very unlikely a
republican-controlled Senate is going to
do it and we're only 20 months from the
election anyway awesome I agree that was
my only question okay thank you for the
call really appreciate it great to hear
from you let's go to the nine one three
area code caller from nine one three
who's there
where are you calling from yeah hi my
name is Stacey I'm calling from Kansas
City Missouri it's at Walden I went
three from Kansas but it's all right
very good I was in Kansas City Missouri
once yeah it's a great city
if you haven't been there I mean for
people who haven't been there people
other than I'm I'm a black American and
I can tell I want I just wanted I called
because uh me being a black American I
think this is important to the state is
the majority of black Americans really
don't care about reparations anymore we
have more important topics to talk about
and you know okay so when you say a
majority of black Americans don't care
about reparations what are you basing
that on well I I said I should stayed
the majority of maybe Midwestern black
Americans okay what do you really do
that or not I'm a part of multiple black
organizations most of my clients are
black Americans we don't talk about
reparations we're mostly more focused on
reformation of the criminal code and
also housing issues that are going on
within the city limits issues that
directly affect our population because
you know reparations you know is a long
like the whole idea about reparations is
already far gone from our needs and
desires because most of the people that
were promised reparations like my
grandfather for instance there
dead so we just want more criminal
reform you know how is he reform
possibly more employment law focused on
fairness but that I want to state that
but that's not my question for here
today okay my um my question is because
I kind of wanted to ask you more about
the whole Michael Cohen the Michael
Cohen hearing today there was a lot of
allegations centered around Trump pain
Michael Cohen after he became president
and most importantly pained him through
the Trump foundation payments where
Michael Cohen did bring evidence to show
this and even though Michael Cohen
stated a lot of things that were very
controversial I personally think that's
the most important issue because that is
an illegal act that President Trump did
in his office uh do you think that that
will have more focus when it like in
this new cycle or do you think that it's
going to be overlooked by some and
they're going to focus on more issues
it's this new cycle everything is
overlooked by many people because
there's just too much to keep up with so
I don't disagree with you but a lot of
this stuff is going to be overlooked and
I mean just just in today's hearing
there were like eight different
bombshells which in and of themselves
would be front-page stories for a week
if they had they were even alleged under
Obama and you know it's like the sixth
they did the six hours of testimony and
it was crazy and a whole bunch of stuff
will never really be discussed to the
degree that it should because it's just
the type of circumstance we're in and
that's what the news cycle is like right
now okay and and one more one more
question is is like in the Midwest the
progressive movement is is progressing
very fast a lot of I know Missouri is
very conservative but actually if you
look at our voting history when we vote
on questions it's actually we actually
have a very progressive population
could you give some advice as a as a
progressive voice I you know ways to
convince primarily Trump voters because
that's usually the hardest people to
convince that's your mistake may not be
trying to convince that's exactly where
I would say that's not the right you
you're not going to win an election by
convincing Trump voters on any kind of
individual level individual lobbying
efforts by just voters people are going
to be way more effective by getting out
the vote of individuals who often don't
vote and there's huge opportunities in
almost every part of the country to do
that if something major happens in the
news that's just like so groundbreaking
that even Trump voters have to say I
can't vote for the guy that's maybe how
some of them will be convinced but it is
a total misuse of time and effort to be
trying to like argue with Trump voters
into not voting for the guy just it's
just not the right approach so I would
ban together the progressive community
maybe in whatever way make sense in your
community and the focus has to be let's
get people who already don't like the
guy to just go out and vote okay thank
you hey one more thing before you go
when I was in Kansas City Missouri I was
taken to Franklin's barbecue and I was
told like this is the place but when I
went it felt kind of touristy so like is
that is that do people in Kansas City
Missouri see it as a touristy place or
is it still a place people go yeah I'm
sorry you were playing that is
definitely not a place that I would
recommend okay okay now I mean well yeah
usually when you ask the person first
from Kansas City what's the best
barbecue places places everyone
always thinks that's a weird question
because we always like separate it out
do you want ribs do you want meat like
slice needs you know what do you want
there's a rib place there slice needs
place are you a sauce person because if
you're a sauce first thing you should go
to these places but I don't know if you
have a time
to write this down but if you ever come
back to Kansas City if you like ribs
Elsie's no ribs I don't eat pork so for
me it's like brisket is really what I go
for
I mean I might start an accidental
argument with other Kansas City people
header listening in but if you like
slice knees I personally think Arthur
Bryant's is the best but some people
like Oklahoma Jones over that but I
think Arthur Bryant's but that's
President Obama's also his favorite
place to go to as well so interesting
are eggs all right well that'll have to
be the place next time I get brisket in
Kansas City yeah and one more thing
sauce
definitely gate that's I have to put the
gates family in there because they're
also a huge powerhouse in Kansas City is
it a vinegar-based sauce or what what is
it um all Kansas City sauce is our
tomato base oh they are okay see I'm so
clueless I didn't even realize that yeah
it's it's a better choice alright very
good well listen I appreciate the phone
call appreciate the barbecue advice I no
problem okay take care
great to hear from you okay there's a
super chat which says that there are
numerous YouTube channels telling people
not to vote like the advised show I
don't know what that is and I don't
agree with that Jackson also says yes
Cohen's a liar but he lied for Trump
it's like the rejecting the testimony of
a mobster against his boss because the
mobsters also a criminal amazing yeah
good point Jackson I agree with you
that's it for me today I've got to run a
lot of work to do appreciate everybody
who joined me I will do another stream
before you know it and maybe I'll open
up the phone lines then as well